[Musique]
fin de journée au port ici qu'ovide
oblige les entraînements se font en
extérieur mais rien qui peut altérer
leur motivation qui n'a pas menti le
report un ordinateur pour graver des
montagnes bac 2 dans les sept jeunes
boxeuses c'est margot son master 2 de
sciences politiques en poche elle a
décidé de prendre le chemin du
volontariat international voulait
apprendre à boxer et donc j'ai rencontré
monsieur reste que j'habite dans le
secteur et en discutant en fait en
parlant un peu de ce que je voulais
faire
il m'a il m'a présenté le programme de
coopération du département et c'est
comme ça que j'ai pu envoyer mon cv la
lettre de motivation après je
m'attendais pas à décrocher enfin à
décrocher un emploi en venant boxer mais
je pense que c'est quand on dit voilà
déclenché sa chance et surtout savoir
saisir les opportunités qui s'offrent
donc là on va voir boxer cette
expérience de coopération soutenue par
le département correspond à la dynamique
de cette association sportive
rien d'impossible et le monde qu'un
village faut l'admettre et que faut
donner envie de donner toujours légende
envie d'aller voir plus loin des voiries
et espaces des sportifs au grand coeur
qui termine tout juste trois années de
coopération avec leurs frères de
tamatave tamatave
il ya un cyclone qui est passé il ya eu
malheureusement des dégâts leur salle de
sport a été complètement abîmé il faut
tout refaire et les moyens ne suffisent
pas les moyens de l'état mariage ne
suffisent pas
maintenant on est devenu en tant que
frère de gand fin de sports de combat
emporter notre soutien le département
nous a aidés dans le financement de la
formation puisque dans notre projet
comme je disais ça fait dans le temps
pluriannuel comme le disait tout à
l'heure
donc on a proposé des gens formés qui
auront fait de la formation à des fins
limiers
[Musique]
ensemble les limites on bison simplement
construit un vrai ring une oeuvre
collective qui a du sens
cette expérience dépasse largement le
cadre sportif monter sur le ring
nécessite du courage peut être le même
que d'aller vers les autres
billy et boxer et encadrant le sport lui
a donné une autre vision du monde
mais là bas ils sont livrés à eux mêmes
et ça fait un choc au début surtout moi
j'ai pas beaucoup voyagé
par chance avec l'album j'ai eu la
chance ça ça m'a fait un choc les deux
premiers jours je n'étais pas dans mon
assiette et c'était compliqué de
d'échanger avec eux parce que nous on a
un luxe qui l'ont pas genre ali pour sa
talents nous c'est normal tu vois là
pour eux c'est un luxe
nous voudrions tous chez nos jeunes en
leur disant le plus grand développement
qui se fera dans les 20 à 30 prochaines
années
c'est dans lydiane océanis sa part de
l'afrique jusqu'à va dire la chine
l'autre poser maintenant mon devoir de
roseaux que si vous avez la possibilité
de faire fort plus ça fait réaliser ce
qu'on a et ça rend humble bilan de cette
action de coopération une assistance
logistique des nouvelles rencontres de
l'emploi une progression sportive et
beaucoup de gens heureux
ce qui peut être aussi important pour le
rayonnement de notre india ocr
[Musique]